hello
good morning again
the uh
committee meeting is being live streamed
so very minds that anything can be seen
after
so so this is the uh decision of the
subcommittee
the committee has considered all written
evidence and the representation
representations made at the hearing an
additional written representation
received from the interested party who
was unable to attend the meeting
in the hearing today the committee has
also considered the step
set the steps set out on page
4.21 which the applicants will take in
order to promote the four licensing
objectives
the condition are as follows
which again is the principle of
prevention of crime and disorders
the premises license holder will
maintain a digital cctv system that
covers the premises including the main
area which will be used for display of
alcohol
the cctv images will be retained for 31
days a member of the management team
will be on the premises at the times the
store is open
and will be the initial point of contact
for any issues that may arise
public safety the premises license
holder will maintain
policies and procedures in
relation to relevant obligations and
legislation these will be available upon
request
prevention of public nuisance the
premises will demonstrate a good
neighbor ethos and
that they play an attractive part in the
local community
protection and protection of child
children from harm the premises will
operate i think 25 policy the checkouts
will be programmed to prompt the
customer assistant when an alcohol
product is scanned at the checkout to
follow the thing 25 policy
all colleagues will receive training in
relation to the underlying
law policy systems and procedures this
training will be documented and
refresher training will be provided on a
regular basis
these will be available
upon request
the committee has carefully considered
the concerns raised by the interested
party relating to the license objectives
of prevention of public nuisance however
the committee is mindful of the fact
that no representations representations
have been made by essex police and
environmental health
the committee has taken into
consideration the applicant's verbal
representations relating to their
experience of running similar premises
elsewhere and its commitment to work
with local residents the committee is
satisfied that the concerns
of the interested party related to noise
will be addressed by the applicant
the committee has resolved to grant the
premises license subject to the usual
the usual mandatory conditions and the
additional conditions already included
above this concludes the hearing thank
you for attending have a nice afternoon
thank you
thank you